so we have completely predictable and
yet Blockbuster bombshell news related
to this Russian bounty story so
yesterday we we kind of gave you the
initial outline of this story as the
story goes we learned a few days ago
thanks to reporting from the New York
Times that Russia was offering cash
bounties it's like a bonus for Taliban
connected troops who killed us or
coalition troops in Afghanistan and
immediately the question was does Trump
know about this did Trump know about
this was Trump aware of this when he was
glad-handing with Vladimir Putin saying
Putin should be part of the g8 let's
make the g7 the g8 again we heard
nothing from the White House for 24
hours then we started getting statements
that Trump was never briefed on it
Trump simply had no idea why wasn't
Trump briefed it wasn't really clear
there were claims that it wasn't
considered credible enough to brief
Donald Trump there were claims that it
just Trump doesn't get briefed about
everything that's going on but it was
weird because we knew that the National
Security Council had indeed taken up
this issue we started hearing from other
elected officials who said well I had
heard about this issue we learned that
British intelligence and top British
politicians were aware of and discussing
this so it started to become a little
difficult to believe that Donald Trump
had not actually been briefed but they
insisted on it Kaleigh McKenna knee
Donald Trump's press secretary when
asked about this said and indeed that
Donald Trump was not briefed because the
intelligence was not credible I'll say
this that the u.s. receives thousands of
reports a day on intelligence and they
are subject to strict scrutiny while the
White House does not routinely comment
on alleged intelligence or internal
deliberations the CIA director NSA
national security adviser and the chief
of staff can all confirm the neither the
president nor the vice president were
briefed on the alleged front-foot
Russian bounty intelligence has he been
breathe since all of these repairs came
out so let me back up and say this that
there is no consensus within the
intelligence community on these
allegations and in in effect there are
dissenting opinions from some in the
intelligence community with regards to
the veracity of what's being reported
and the veracity of the underlying
allegations continue to be evaluated so
again it didn't really pass the sniff
test we knew it went to the National
Security Council and now we have
multiple sources saying that Trump knew
all along
anybody shocked the New York Times The
Associated Press CNN all reporting about
different sources who say Trump was
briefed Trump knew so let's go through
some of the different claims there's a
New York Times report which says that
Trump was briefed in February of this
year okay so that would be like four or
five months ago and that Trump was
briefed about the Russian bounties in
his presidential daily briefing now the
thing about it being in the presidential
daily briefing is that we know that that
has been a challenging text for Donald
Trump
presidential daily briefings with other
presidents have been 30 40 pages long
and come with quite a long briefing with
intelligence staff Donald Trump doesn't
read oftentimes as he has been given the
briefings he's watching a TV that's in
the back of the room the presidential
daily briefing was shortened short and
shortened all the way to one page one
page was too much so it was shortened to
just a few bullet points with a picture
or two like a graph or a chart and even
then we don't know that Donald Trump is
actually looking at it so it seems as
though it was at minimum in the
presidential daily briefing whether
Trump actually looked at it is a
question mark whether Trump remembers it
is another question mark because as
we've said before Donald Trump and his
memory problems there have been wide
allegations that Trump genuinely doesn't
remember a damn thing so that's the New
York Times report then we have a CNN
report CNN has its own sources which say
that Donald Trump was briefed directly
about the Russian bounty story in spring
so spring could be March April May ish
the New York Times report says certainly
February 2020 the CNN report says it was
a little more recent sometime in spring
of 2020 you then have a third report
from The Associated Press which says
that top officials in the White House
were aware of the Russian Bounty's
situation early last year in 2019 a full
year earlier than the New York Times and
associate and CNN are currently
reporting and then we heard from
Democratic Senator Chris Murphy who says
that the argument that this was not
credible information is is a wrong it's
a bad argument
that he saw the intelligence that it is
clearly not a hoax and that that would
not be a valid reason for keeping this
information from Donald Trump so on day
one really day two because they didn't
say anything about it for 24 hours when
the White House first said Trump was
never briefed we assumed that that was a
lie
the details are now confirming it with
New York Times CNN and Associated Press
sources all saying the president was
indeed briefed this sort of reminded me
you know Trump has this hear no evil see
no evil sort of mentality Trump recently
said multiple times I was encouraging
less testing because less testing means
we find fewer cases it would be
analogous to saying if we cancel Border
Patrol we're not going to catch anybody
crossing the border problem solved right
this is sort of another example of that
if Trump stops reading reports on
terrorism or he pretends they don't
exist or he ignores them then it's sort
of like the Terrorism isn't going on if
he doesn't remember or doesn't read or
doesn't pay attention to the Russian
bounty story it's sort of like it's not
going on and of course the implications
are absolutely insane Donald Trump
allegedly being aware of the Russian
Bounty's story still was publicly
arguing that he wants Vladimir Putin and
Russia back in the g7 to make at the g8
Trump invited the Taliban to go to Camp
David and meet with him allegedly after
knowing that they were being paid
bounties when they were killed
u.s. or coalition troops Trump ended up
having to cancel that secret meeting
with the Taliban because things went
haywire and people rightly said what the
hell are you doing here what it what
exactly is the idea here
abruptly getting cancelled Trump was
withholding aid to Ukraine an ally aid
that would have been used to resist
aggression from Russia after he was
briefed that Russia was offering
bounties when Taliban linked individuals
killed u.s. or coalition forces so that
none of it is surprising the lies are
not surprising the duplicitous nature of
what's being said it not none of it is
surprising but I think now we don't want
to get stuck on when did Trump know and
did Trump know from clearly was told and
he was told a while ago whether he
retained it or not that's that's a
different question Trump now knows it's
now been what are we on day five since
this story broke
what is Trump doing now what is Trump
done since finding out last week we're
hearing very little about that and that
is arguably as important a story as when
Trump knew and who told him